jake here shown you how to respec in
Dark Souls 3 first thing you'll need to
do is warp to cleansing chapel and head
through these doors if this store isn't
open you'll need to make your way
through the chapel to unlock this
shortcut once it's open hitch a ride on
this elevator head through the archway
and hang an immediate left and climb up
this ladder up down here cross the
rooftop and watch out for enemies
because they will climb up behind you so
now that you're inside this is the ledge
you'll need to get to there's a bunch of
knights patrolling these catwalks so be
careful
not the prettiest landing but you get
the point then hop down here and slay
all the giant banana slugs
once these slugs are dead head up the
stairs and get ready for an ambush
this time after you've killed all them
swing the doors open and here you are
talk to Rosario and once you've joined
the Covenant you can respect and change
your looks but in order to do this you
will need a pale tongue which can be
found within the world or you can earn
them through PvP if you're short on pale
tongues there is one nearby after you've
climbed the ladder and hopped onto the
roof you can find one way back here for
more tips and walkthroughs for Dark
Souls 3 head over to gamespot com
you